wunderschönen abend zu finden nachdem
top der schlagzeilen macht und wir haben
heute brandt heiße themen masken pflicht
lauterbach expertenrat olaf scholz und
dazu gäste die werden heute laut und
heftig diskutiert davon bin ich
überzeugt wolfgang kubicki
bundestagsvize und jorge star kolumnist
freue mich riesig und nina schenk
buchautorin und wild kollegin und
philipp amthor
cdu-abgeordnete und sie wissen beispiel
nachts wurde viel und laut insbesondere
von dieser kollegen über ein thema immer
wieder diskutiert die masken pflicht und
jetzt werden sie ganz neidisch auf ein
land schauen denn da passiert heute
etwas historisches in london da fällt in
england da fällt die masken pflicht und
deswegen bevor nena schenkt uns ihre
meinung zu masken pflicht sagt möchten
einmal hin schalten zu unserer kollegin
annika rasch bild reporterin die gerade
in england in london vor ort ist annika
wie fühlt sich das an ein leben ohne
maske wir wissen dass wir alle nicht
mehr erzähl uns ein bisschen
sender geht sozusagen in werden hier in
deutschland darüber dass wir an die
maßnahmen noch weiter zu verschärfen
und wieso machst du besser gefallen
sozusagen denn man braucht im leben
tatsächlich einhalten gesprächen keine
massen mehr ich will jetzt hier aber
übergehen fläche mitten auf der retweet
also der einkaufsstraße von sonnenbrand
dieser mir in dem geschäft
keiner direkt am eingang zu sehen aber
man muss eine marke gemerkt sagen wenn
man rein gibt kann man also ganz
entspannt ohne masken haben aber auch
die empfehlung der
sozusagen aufgestellt worden und man
braucht auch in kraft und
ich muss nicht verschweigen oder
halt ein reisender aus deutschland
wenn ich ein reichlich muss gleich
machbarkeit zu schmecken aber gab es
keine der grund dafür ist vereinzelt
gute user
mittlerweile haben ihre sechs
geschwister in ihren dritten tag
und das bei gleicher instrument machen
jetzt druck zu sagen
danke eine der annika wir sind alle ganz
neidisch auf dich und ich wünsche dir
jetzt erst mal dass du in die kneipe
gehst ohne maske deine maske weg hier
ist und die anschaust was nina schenk
dazu zu sagen hat
japan ich pflege morgen früh nach london
also ankara will follow you und ich
freue mich auf ein wochenende mit einer
sehr guten freundin ohne maske also ich
kann so wenig erwarten keine masken zu
tragen dass ich morgen früh den ersten
flieger schon nach london nehme ich
finde dass die maske endlich auch in
deutschland die masken pflicht fallen
muss ich habe schon oft gefordert ich
wurde sehr hart dafür auch teilweise
überall beschrieben als chorleiterin als
diffamierung also sich nur diffamieren
würde aber ich bin der überzeugung die
massen pflichten muss jetzt weg england
hat den freedom day 2.0 der hat noch nie
in freedom day wir hätten ihn gebraucht
wir brauchen ihn jetzt wieder weil das
größte versagen der politik ist für mich
dass wir seit 22 jahren durchgängig die
masken pflicht haben also ich kann also
vielleicht kann mir heute abend ein
politiker hier am tisch erklären philipp
abenteuer bei der partei die lange
regiert hat herr kubicki der partei die
jetzt regiert warum seit zwei jahren
durchgängig die massen pflicht gilt ich
bin dafür dass jetzt endlich die massen
pflicht feld ich habe keinen musste
philipp ampel historischer tag heute in
london in england wann fällt bei uns
endlich die maske waren werfen wir die
bag naja ich glaube erst mal dass sie
jetzt irgendwann fallen muss die masken
pflicht ist richtig ich glaube der
zeitpunkt ist dafür jetzt noch nicht
gekommen wenn wir uns das
infektionsgeschehen angucken ich teile
deine befunden zu sagen man hat darauf
keine wirkliche lust mehr das macht uns
schon wieder das ist jetzt der tag nicht
da also eines gilt wieder nicht ändern
geht alles her was haben sie falsch
gemacht mit ihrer verteilt
also ich glaube wir haben in der ganzen
frage der maßnahmen ist es glaube ich
ein bisschen einseitig jetzt zu sagen
man gucken auf eine partei ist am ende
eine gemeinsame
nein das sage ich nicht die länder haben
auch freiheiten dazu die ganze frage der
masken pflicht auch zu lockern und ich
glaube auch wenn wir uns die
gesellschaftliche erwartung angucken
wird das jetzt auch martin fusion seien
die auf wahren bekommt ich werde jetzt
hier keinen tag nennen am ende heißt es
ja auch immer wir sollen dann nicht
hinter unsere versprechen wieder
zurückfallen da guckt bild ja auch genau
hin hat jemand der jetzt mit regiert ist
wolfgang kubicki herr kubicki sie habe
ich mal besucht in strande da haben wir
über ihre stammkneipe diskutiert was
sagt die stammkneipe zu machen
vielleicht hätte fatale folgen die
öffentliche äußerung von mir heiß
gewesen machen ja genau aber da gibt es
auch passende mann und eine frau waren
die stammkneipe ist die masse nicht das
geringste problem weil wenn wir am tisch
sitzen tragen wir keine maske tragen wir
nur beim treten des restaurants und auch
sozusagen der öffentlichkeit besteht
kein masten pflichtig das ist für mich
ist das geringste problem ich glaube wir
müssen die anderen maßnahmen anfangen
zweig plus in restaurants macht
überhaupt keinen sinn weil wir ja gfd
vor giften schützen oder geben bevor
gewusst hat oder umgekehrt schützen denn
ich stellte mir momentan in restaurants
kann hinein die nicht nachgewiesen haben
dass ich eben foren sind zweig im
einzahlen macht keinen sinn weil wir
festgestellt haben und zwar definitiv
dass wir im einzelhandel war die
lebensmittelgeschäften keinen
infektionsgeschehen hatten und das
gleiche gilt jetzt selbstverständlich
für kleidungsgeschäft und andere dinge
mehr das ist das erste was passieren
muss und ich glaube dass wir uns über
die frage der masken vielleicht in drei
wochen nicht wirklich unterhalten werden
denn das was großbritannien auch
dänemark das land in dem ich sehr
nahestehe mir auch keine basta nicht
mehr am ersten februar was die machen
liegt daran dass die mikrowelle über sie
zwei bis drei wochen vor hinweg gerollt
ist die machen das jetzt zwar das heißt
drei wochen fällt die meist nicht bei
uns ob sie fällt weiß ich nicht aber sie
wird immer weniger sinnvoll und sie
werden trotzdem erleben dafür die werden
trotzdem mein leben nein ich bin dafür
dass sie dann auch aufgehoben die
frühesten sind drei wochen aber
unerwünscht bei uns werden sie erleben
darunter ist das zwar dass viele daran
dass viele menschen die maske
weitertragen werden vor allen dingen im
winter weil sie festgestellt völlig in
ordnung dass ich das auch machen ich bin
ich in berlin der u-bahn fahre dann hat
sie bei mir wirklich da nur fest ist mal
wirklich sind eine maske tragen vor
allem weil wir noch andere
infektionsgeschehen heimlich nur grüne
an ich bin mir bereitwillig auch völlig
in ordnung freiwillig das entscheiden
allein 13 tage wochen nach der
mikrowelle werden eine sache sagen ob
philipp an trotz angesprochen und dann
hat das schon mal verfügt da gibt es den
freedom day und alles weg dänemark auch
und dann kann er ja mal der hat seine
ganz eigene agenda der ist in größter
not stolpert von einer aufgeflogenen
party in den exter und muss an sein amt
kämpfen natürlich will dass ich auch mit
irgendwas beliebt machen die masken
schlecht ich erinnere mich noch als die
gekommen ist hat setzt herr ila vom rk
ii gesagt die nützt gar nichts erinnert
ihr euch noch so hat es mal angefangen
ich heute als brillenträger hasse masken
weil jedes land bei diesem winterwetter
eingetreten kann ich in den ersten in
der ersten viertelstunde die waren nicht
erklären ich gerne kaufen würde weil die
brille beschlagen also es ist grauenhaft
sieht das nicht aber ja da schnappe
arten
jedenfalls ich glaube aber umgekehrt
muss ich sagen realistisch den deutschen
ist jetzt in den zwei jahren so viel
angst eingeredet worden dass vor allem
ältere frauen in fünf jahren noch masken
tragen werden und dass das in
deutschland das letzte sein wird was
fällt da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher
obwohl die freiheitspartei von herrn
kubicki so hat man die band tituliert in
der opposition noch nicht mehr so viel
von übrig gandhi oder die intelligenz
ist halt immer in der minderheit und
auch die freiheit hat in deutschland
nicht unbedingt eine mehrheit das haben
meine letzten zwei jahren gemerkt ich
halte viel sehr mutig was er gesagt hat
in drei wochen ist das weg ich kann es
nicht ganz glauben weil ich kann mir
schon alle vorstellen die da unterwegs
sind angefangen von herrn lauterbach
sofern er dann noch im amt ist kommen
wir später dazu aber anders kommen wir
später also wir haben aus der eso
forscher mittlerweile die erkenntnis
dass basken im freien gar keinen sinn
machen sich nicht anstecken außer man
busselt sich ab wie ich das hier gerade
gesehen habe zwischen ehrenamt und
anderen netten gästen hier sind dann
kann man sich anstecken aber sonst noch
frei ist nahezu unmöglich oder haben sie
denn so also normalerweise wie ist es
weil da wird ja auch viel drüber
gesprochen gibt man sich wieder die hand
oder macht man immer noch dieses absurde
hier und hier sind wir denn da brauchen
wir ihn am kopf nein ich frage
frage wie haben sie überraschende themen
oder sie schön sind sie wieder die hand
ehrlicherweise überwiegend heute aber
ihre hände geschüttelt überwiegen bin
ich immer noch bei der bei der korona
faust ich nehme aber auch war muss ich
schon sagen im wahlkreis gilt ja schon
teilweise als sehr distanziert wenn man
es macht also ich habe persönlich auch
kein problem mit hand geben wenn man
sich besser kennen sie auch immer doch
gerade im magen und doch gerade
angesteuert habe ich hoffe ich habe
nicht gesagt wie hast du kein auto jetzt
also ich habe philipp küsschen links
küsschen rechts gehen was hab ich ja
auch schon aufgedrängt du ja ich mache
alles andere ich hab schon schlimmere
die hier also dass da wo wir sind zwei
erwachsenen menschen die sich übrigens
was früher normal war war schnell zum
hallo sagen aber im sommer mag also ich
sag vielen küsschen links küsschen
rechts ich finde das auch mache ich
immer so habe ich übrigens heute auch
mit uni wir nach zwei
kopien eines
gar nicht
dürfen doch zwei erwachsenen menschen
gemeinsam entscheiden wie sie sich
begriff so lohnt wird es wieder benutzt
ja der herr am tor der busse da wir
sollten uns daran gewöhnt blöden vollste
uns wieder abzutrainieren und die hände
zu jahren zu bestrafen aber man muss
auch sagen aber da sind lassen das
beispiel wenn man dann ich mache schon
bei journalisten oft aus sicherheit sag
ich mal weil ich habe ganz
unterschiedliche reaktionen händels
portmonee clown einig war ein ich mag es
manchmal dann tatsächlich so dass ich
dann die hand entgegenstrecken und mir
dann von manchen eltern anhören es sei
doch noch corona das ist doch jetzt
bei uns dieses ungewöhnlichen schließen
sich die hand zu geben da begrüßen wenn
sie mit einem kopfnicken mit einem
fröhlichen moin und dann hat das auch
haben schon noch einmal kurz zurück zu
dem was man von kubicki gesagt er gesagt
in drei wochen fällt die masten pflicht
erste teil der regierung es ermutige als
sie jetzt haben sie doch mal was soll
denn die meisten haben uns also das
entscheidet die regierung ja nicht
alleine die frage masken pflicht ihre
ministerpräsidenten die sich immer noch
als team hart und
also am ende in wirtheim pk diskutiert
wenn ich glaube aber auch einst die
masken pflicht sinnvollerweise sehen wir
auch an den beispielen dänemark und
großbritannien die kann man nicht
isoliert diskutieren also es ist jetzt
ja auch nicht so dass der freedom day
sozusagen nur eine maßnahme betrifft
sondern es dann maßnahmenbündel hier
müssen uns darüber unterhalten
dann sozusagen da einzelne maßnahmen
fallen nur masken pflicht isoliert zu
diskutieren ergibt ja wenig spricht sind
vielen playern und bevor wir weiter über
karl lauterbach diskutieren wollen wir
noch einmal sehen und hören was in
england los ist ein historischer tag
dort die maske fällt und annika ist
immer noch vor ort annika erzähle uns
mal gehen die menschen denn heute
besonders in die geschäfte und sagen
maske herunter jetzt wieder rein
ja ich war tatsächlich schon vor zwei
monaten in der weihnachtszeit war
relativ viel los aber weniger als sonst
und gerade heute auch gegen abend merkt
man das jetzt auch die leute nach der
arbeit die geschäfte strömen wir können
jetzt noch einmal befinde
dann sehen wir auch hier ein geschäft wo
auch die menschen keine maske tragen
müssen
die eigenverantwortung setzt der
bürgermeister hat gesagt du right thing
also macht das nicht gut das wichtige
ist also so ein bisschen auf den
schwierigen weg gehen wer auch immer bei
bild verfolgt haben und man muss auch
wirklich sagen die menschen haben dabei
gewinnt und genießen das jetzt wieder
ein bisschen freiheit zu atmen kann ich
ja eine frage noch unser star -kolumnist
new yorks hat gesagt es könnte auch ein
bisschen damit zu tun haben dass bosch
sonst ein anderes thema setzen will weil
er ja so ein bisschen in der bredouille
ist es dass auch das gefühl
das ist auf jeden fall meine
uhr eingeläutet
also er wollte sagt ich den leuten oder
den menschen und den medien etwas zu
werfen die sich sozusagen das was man
rotes fleisch und dass sie sozusagen auf
eine andere ist nena fans und nicht auf
das geld das sie vielleicht zum schluss
bringen könnte in den nächsten tagen